it's great to be here and I want to
start maybe somewhere a little unusual
but I want to talk about bodybuilding
let's do it what what was it that Drew
you to that and maybe more importantly
what did you learn from what I'll call
one of the most intense disciplines in
the world so when I was uh 14 years old
I was 6'1 uh 135 and my name wasn't Tyra
Banks that's that's what I got the body
will do and that there was a commercial
maybe you'll remember this there was a
commercial that said uh you know I used
to be skinny you know rejected by girls
and now I drink milk and you know I I
don't know if I remember that commercial
the milk commercial so for me I said man
I need some muscles because I I need a
date I need girls I need to go out I
need to protect myself and I started
hitting the weights at 14 years old I
would go to the gym with three sweaters
on and there was a guy in there named
Fred
uh who took a liking into me was like
five years older than me and uh I was
benching the bar you know the bar is 45
pounds and when you don't have a lot of
strength when you you know bench the bar
the bar is shaking right say Pullman
says come here kid don't look at anybody
you're gonna have a two and a half pound
rule on what you're gonna do every week
we're going to increase your bench by
two and a half pounds and that's all you
need to do and then from there that
whole two and a half pound idea I
applied in business and everywhere else
and it worked because uh that led me to
you know I was in the Army I had in my
room was all you know posters of Arnold
of Ronnie Coleman of Aaron Baker of
Chris Cormier of Lee Haney all of these
guys and that's what I'm gonna run for
I'm gonna go be in Astro Olympia one day
what did Arnold represent to you
uh Arnold represented to me uh the story
of an immigrant with a fire to prove a
point uh that he wanted to control the
narrative you know when I say
controlling the narrative to me is he's
uh written the story for his life you
know Winston Churchill said many years
ago history will be kind to me for I
intend to write it I think Arnold wrote
his history this is what I'm going to be
doing you know I'm going to come here
I'm going to compete I'm going to win
I'm going to go into Hollywood I have an
accent with or without it I'm still
going to go into Hollywood I'm going to
marry you Kennedy I'm going to go and be
a governor and I'm going to do what I
want to do my life he was an example of
this is possible so the thing that I
find interesting about bodybuilding
because I started lifting in my mid-20s
ish and for me it was very different I
grew up in a morbidly obese family so I
was somewhat trying to escape that but
quite frankly I wanted to look like Hugh
Jackman so that was my obsession
um that was right at the Heyday of the
X-Men franchise exactly right oh man I
was I was just about it and I really did
hate it I hated every minute of being in
the gym but there was something to that
the this this discipline the two and a
half pound rule you know of every time
that I cycle through a body part I've
got to be a little bit stronger a little
bit stronger a Little Bit Stronger
and my partners and I used to talk a lot
about what's super weird is here we are
where these three entrepreneurs were
using discipline in lifting in the exact
same way that we would use it in
business the ability to push through
something hard the demand that you grow
and get better and we were looking at
other people and Arnold became
fascinating to us because he was the
only one that could apply it to every
area of his life like what made him
great in bodybuilding and I think my
favorite Schwarzenegger quote is
somebody said to him I don't want to
look like you and he said don't worry
you won't and like the the truth and the
sort of wonderful arrogance of that
quote of how hard it is that it's never
going to happen by accident but it's
always fascinated me how few
bodybuilders are able to translate that
discipline how are you able to take that
and apply it to business and other
things I gotta tell you I'm surprised
you're asking this question because no
one asked this question but everything
that I've done post bodybuilding goes
back to bodybuilding it's amazing when I
tell you everything uh in bodybuilding
you'll learn areas you miss out on which
is what most people don't do legs you
know Arnold at the beginning stage of
this currency would take pictures in the
water because you know he didn't want to
show his calf so he would always do
thighs because he had the thighs but he
didn't have the calves so I'm doing a
pose with the uh minimizing the calves
and he started doing the donkey raises
with Franco Columbu on his back and
really got focused about the Cavs and he
had these massive calves in business it
could be the same thing you could be all
good on front end you know marketing but
your operation sucks and for me I was so
front end I was so sales that I wasn't
good in operations and I didn't pay
attention to the systems I didn't pay
attention to we don't need technology we
don't need to look at automation we
don't look at this we need more
marketing we need to do this and finally
the conversation got deeper and deeper
and deeper to the point where we have to
pay attention to them my wife pulled me
in and she brought the board in she
brought everybody and everybody sat
there and says we need to invest in
technology
and uh when we did that I could scale
because now you have a knob and whenever
you have a knob to control and you you
increase it a little bit when flow is
coming in that's what really helped us
grow the business to a different level
so yeah when I look at bodybuilding and
what that did to my life business-wise
everything went back to small little
growth right beating your prior best and
then shocking your business because
that's like a new campaign new
initiative so same thing with business
so I would say a lot of it applied from
that into business for me I loved the um
the life of an entrepreneur in 90
seconds it's basically that it's how to
build yourself Brick by Brick you're
talking about how you see the flash you
see the cars the money the house but you
don't see the times they were freaking
out stress anxiety things were going
wrong and they had to just get better
every day and by doing that day after
day after day they're able to really
turn themselves into a beast and one of
my favorite stories about what you're
talking about with Arnold and his Cavs
is so he goes through the phase where at
first he said standing in the water and
he doesn't let himself be photographed
and then he flips it and he makes a
sweatsuit where the only part that's
visible are his calves so that he could
never distract himself with something
that looked good and he would walk
around the gym with his worst body part
exposed so that he'd make sure that he'd
put in the work
[Music]